helps Gumrah a spear too bad today we're
gonna play some PewDiePie games some
games that you bros have made which is
really awesome to be how talented you
guys
oh god copyrighted music the series no
one could get no know what the last time
for a game was meant to be the last of
this series but a higher call made it
come back what the [ __ ] is this oh god
what the hell is that why do I look so
beautiful I mean I always look beautiful
in my neck does not look weird at all
thank you
oh hello there of course of course
oh yes the duck feet because why not
oh hello
what the [ __ ] Prez why do you Oh God
that was this where am I going
I just did all of then while playing if
you think it's a bad game calm down and
rethink okay a nice mustache tired in
the background pew duck pie there's a
level selection level there's three
levels okay well let's do this [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] fantastic best game at oh god
what the [ __ ] I am Shh great animations
nailed it [ __ ] you [ __ ] you so pissed
where are you going mate where are you
going yeah I can almost fly oh come on
dad Oh dirt dirt dirt dirt oh no dude
Oh what the [ __ ] was that you tricked me
know how unhappy yes
like why so sour bro yeah duck Oh got
another one doc power na what the [ __ ]
I'm supposed to go up there at least I
look fabulous well dying it's a shut up
if you're not fabulous like I am when
I'm dying so shut up oh god what oh I
got smooshed come on
IGN 11 out of 10 best game ever made
probably not ah [ __ ] come on there we go
mother [ __ ] the graphics are so good
what I jumped on in I got a sucks there
we go No too fat for you mother [ __ ]
there we go come on oh my god alright
here we go
mother of dick stains in every [ __ ] you
I'm after space mother you little dodgy
come what
ain't no stereo loan on my milk right
now alright so balls bounce on their
balls huh
well [ __ ] physics this loves how that
flagpoles goes up his anus oh yeah slope
that's the sound of a flagpole going
inside a bull's anus flip yep you heard
it here first
now today mr. bowl not too if you have a
pink beautiful skirt then we can talk
all right yes [ __ ]
I am the best stuck in the planet I'm a
[ __ ] nook I can quack all day
long girl oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god what has happened in what is that
what is this what the actual my face no
I got y'all watch um racist cloud racist
Chinese cloud Oh God
I got hidden like that [ __ ] this [ __ ]
that [ __ ] lamp
man yeah ditto I wonder if I can trick
the cloud [ __ ] I can't where the [ __ ] am
i what is life what is life what is love
shrek oh oh did you see that [ __ ] oh-ho
go go go go go go go Oh what the [ __ ] a
moccasin for [ __ ] what why my old
bloody and [ __ ] looks disgusting I used
to be so fab it just looks like my I
haven't shaved my legs or some [ __ ]
I have I promise I'm not a skank many
free LVT so what happens if I go
underneath I want to try it maybe just
Oh God oh I can't I can't that fit done
man hey hey
nay well Angela Java love core can I
[ __ ] hate this part
[ __ ] you Chinese cloud I don't need you
in my life I have a boyfriend
he's more Sugoi than your what if I can
just jump through these [ __ ] yeah
what he can change direction of his anus
in the air my god I heard of some super
powers like invisibility or going back
in time and maybe milking nips by
changing ass in the air that's that's
just the best super ability I've ever
[ __ ] heard him I look so beaten up
I feel beaten up [ __ ] you Claude okay
okay come on come on come on come on
come on
wha what wha
told you [ __ ] don't be waiting for the
green light then jump what the [ __ ] oh I
just did it isn't that enough
what do you want from me dinosaur what
do you want from me Danny sir Hey this
calf is a party I hate this [ __ ] game
I hate you so [ __ ] much I don't know
what the [ __ ] else to say [ __ ] you
Jennings cloud no good alright alright
alright alright
jump jump don't stop dice dice this
alright alright alright alright alright
alright alright well then wait for the
green then delay it huh
[Laughter]
oh I see you Shh
scheisse a little bi say [ __ ] this
[ __ ] game
[ __ ] it so [ __ ] much I hate this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
I hate did so [ __ ] much jump you
piece of anus manfully feet - yeah
blackhawk marker a hella birthday
many cute Gaddafi feet [ __ ] you no no
you stole my flag you [ __ ] the only
thing that the reason why I'm keep
playing this game is because I look
[ __ ] Sugoi in that dress this is said
this is my moment this is my record
black [ __ ] [ __ ] go hope I didn't
kick oh how do they dude I think I
popped the name in vain in my [ __ ]
neck night-night
meaning beat defeat that can you look
cute
go go go go go
oh how did it get buddy flip the poor
how like your brother flipped a pop pop
pop there we go there we go there we go
wait for the green light and then jump
[Music]
jumping I am jumping what the [ __ ]
mmm night-night
9 dispels psyched just go just go just
go just [ __ ] go just [ __ ] go I
hate you I hate you with a passion oh
yeah that makes sense
zamak sense let's do that Hey Oh
everything bad in the universe make
sense when I play this [ __ ] game war
killing Justin Bieber I can I can now
understand a Colvin an ally
Mandy jävla kook rub [ __ ] this [ __ ]
game
[ __ ] it so [ __ ] much I hate this
piece of [ __ ] I can't just good enough
nothing racist against Chinese clouds is
is that I really don't like you man hope
but I wouldn't push good gasps wow wow
wow all right so here's this [ __ ]
part that I don't understand wait for
the medieval fancy Asif
wait for the green light then jump and
they said suck a dick they said I don't
understand I just I just I just I just I
just I can't I can't
Steve Jobs invented it go stop oh
can i solicit oh I'm jumping and jumping
even though you alright - [ __ ] that game
now we're gonna play another rage game
it's called peedee peedee peedee pie
flap this game is made by a bro named
Nick and okay I can select for me much
yeah or polka Chan where the [ __ ] is my
character [ __ ]
yeah damn man I don't want to I don't
want to play flappy bird yes
yeah but the background totally changed
amazing
Pete if I doesn't flap you faps let's be
honest here come on gimme gimme 20 I
want 20 [ __ ] a duck man I'm like all
emptied on rage from the other game
seriously i i'm not even faced by it
anymore
yes come on come on yes uh-oh bitte
bitte bitte come on
20 oh please don't die now i'm gonna be
so pissed don't you dare bro freeze me
come on I want 20 it's my lucky number
no bye smart this is like flappy birds
evil spawn no come on 10 more [ __ ]
Medine jävla ballet Jesus Christ on a
bike man you're [ __ ] in barrels I
thought we were through I thought this
joke was over I thought we just move on
with our lives
no after a helluva this table this
cannot be good for my mental health man
I'm gonna end up in a psychiatry or some
[ __ ] like that
y'all y'all y'all y'all yes baby come on
now don't let me down because I want you
in my salad bar on top of it
[Music]
silver brofist thank you thank you go
ahead and maybe like if you enjoy
watching it subscribe Hollow Earth today
and I'll see you tomorrow breakfast
British roughly